all right um
god check this out this is kind of funny
all right i brought in one of my good
friends very very funny comedian thank
you for coming by me yeah of course you
know it's always cool to meet comedians
and like you recognize me yeah you're a
good looking guy you're successful you
get to have some success and like
somebody knows it or whatever and you're
like okay i'm you know yeah i did
something well yeah
well we have actually a pretty natural
classic
uh archetype comedy dynamic right it's
wacky guy straight guy basically you
know yeah cause you have like you'll
always kind of surprise me with like
your references to like anything i'm
like this dude has deep knowledge about
things i don't expect dude i just have a
big dick
i identify with what you're saying a
hundred percent i i feel the same
as you i feel like a lot of people be
like no way
i know it's very strange and i that's
the thing is when you have a a like a
small dick then you look at
what an extreme version of it is and
you're like
that seems pretty awful it's really
really sad that's why it's so great to
meet lesbians they don't care and
they're not yeah wowed by it they're not
influenced by it they don't have any
interest in it right you know this is a
perfect time to segue mm-hmm okay
there's so it goes on and on um let me
give the proper credit here uploaded to
youtube at
joke world
that's who did it
um and the world is w-r-l-d
he kept this for over like four minutes
i love it and he really overlapped your
reactions to like yeah yeah it's so good
yeah it always amazes me because the
amount of time it must take to do this
right this is like a real understanding
it's like those phony phone calls we get
yeah you're like how the [ __ ]
it takes hours huh
[Music]
you